tonight it's et's summer movie preview
hi Barbie hi Ken your Guide to the
Blockbusters coming soon it's epic in
every way from Tom Cruise's most
ambitious Mission yet don't be careful
to be confident to Harrison Ford's final
go as Indiana Jones blew me away plus
only ETS behind the scenes of the new
Transformers
and Disney star-studded haunted mansion
plus everything we know about the most
buzzed about film Barbie it's not what
you think it is
did you bring your rollerblades
I literally go nowhere without them
the summer movie season well it's just
heart of our world welcome everyone to
Entertainment Tonight and happy Memorial
Day Hallie Bailey and Melissa McCarthy
are already making big waves with the
little mermaid after fast 10 Furious box
office debut but another star feeling
the Need for Speed Tom Cruise yes indeed
summer 2022 was all about Maverick but
this go around we are all in on Ethan
Hunt
it's crazy it was great it's it's epic
the scale in every way
how's this for skate scale 500 skydives
over 13 000 Motocross jumps and one
massive ramp to nowhere
don't be careful to be confident be
confident yeah we know all about that
cruise confidence flying jets climbing
the world's tallest buildings and
hanging off the side of a plane and
while Daredevil Toms the king of doing
his own stunts we've never seen anything
like this I have to get so good at this
that there's just no way that I miss my
mark this is your first look behind the
scenes in Norway for the most
spectacular stunt in Tom's latest
Mission the Oscar nominees driving his
motorcycle off this massive cliff and
then somehow Landing with a parachute
okay you train and drill every little
aspect over and over and over and over
again but it's not just about grueling
stunt training Tom's other big challenge
is getting all those state-of-the-art
cameras positioned in just the right
spot each take we can see what height I
am so this way we can set drones and
cameras into places where I can go right
into closer rule one don't hit me with
it because if we do it all we don't
capture it right what's the point let's
do it guys ready yep always wear my
earplugs so I don't hear myself scream
one action
pretty much the biggest stunt in cinema
history
Tom Cruise just rode a motorcycle off a
cliff six times today Mission Impossible
dead reckoning part one was delayed by
the pandemic it's in theaters July 12th
that's five years after the last film in
the franchise Fallout but by the looks
of this worth the wait it's very
rich the movie very rich the story
another billion dollar franchise making
a summer return
this way I'm excited to play the
character again give him hell Indiana
Jones I love making those films they're
great entertainment
[Music]
Indiana Jones and the dial of Destiny
premiered at can but doesn't hit
theaters here until June 30th it marks
the fifth and final time Harrison Ford
will rock that iconic Fedora while also
introducing several new characters I'm
retiring well in that case what are we
drinking Phoebe Waller bridge is the
female lead but not a love interest
playing Dr Jones goddaughter Helena
Antonio Banderas makes his debut in the
franchise a buddy named Ronaldo
he's retiring as a professor and he's
about to stumble into an adventure sorry
some of the film takes place in 1944
about eight years after 1981's Raiders
of the Lost Ark so the now 80 year old
had to be aged down
Dr Jones this is the actual archival
footage of me at that age it's pretty
remarkable I blew me away
after Harrison reunited with his Temple
of Doom co-star he
INE at the Academy Awards fans were
begging to bring him back for a cameo
well uh you know I I want to say yes but
but no I've joked about it all the time
but I will be first in line to one and
we all want to be first in line to see
Ryan Gosling and Margot Robbie and
Barbie this film has been causing
kendemonium since last summer hi Barbie
hi Ken I have that kennergy
were you surprised about how people just
went crazy uh yeah it feels like
anything that happens gets a huge
reaction
so
[Music]
first also Stars Issa Rae as president
Barbie Kate McKinnon as weird Barbie Dua
lipa's a mermaid and Helen mirren's the
narrator whatever you're thinking it's
not it's not that she's right if it's
not what you think it is that's all I
can say okay
otherwise Mattel will come in and box me
up okay
Lisa surgeries out there that there's
some Wizard of Oz maybe connection there
is kind of a parallel there's kind of a
pink brick road I see where that theory
is going I receive it and I love the I
continue to theorize so what do we know
about this patriarchal satire after an
existential crisis the famous Mattel
dolls leave their perfect Barbie world
for the real one and their shiny plastic
lives come crashing down what are you
doing here I'm coming with you
[Music]
did you bring your rollerblades
I literally go nowhere without them
Ken's got no money he's got no job he's
going through some stuff I thought I
might stay over tonight why because
we're girlfriend boyfriend to do what
I'm actually not sure there's also Fish
Out of Water comedy dancing face-offs
with humans I'm the CEO of Mattel and uh
I'm the bad guy very very evil and yeah
plenty of kin's ABS but he's got a
nemesis inter simulator oh looks like
this beach was a little too much Beach
for you Ken so who worked out harder
definitely Ryan I'm gonna 100 he's he's
definitely like a gym in the morning gym
after work kind of guy and as much as I
believe that I do have a work ethic I
also love
food and Barbie's not the only childhood
toy coming to the big screen this summer
you brought a human here I'm nobody I
ain't even seeing nothing I I mean I'm
not even seeing anything right now
what's up ET what's up ET how you doing
we're here in what we call the maximal
caves the maximals of the of the the
animal-like Transformers but here uh we
find the enemy of the maximal we
discover the Predacons
Maxie what and Preta who these are two
new Robo races in Transformers rise of
the beast in theaters June 9th it's the
seventh film in the nearly five billion
dollar franchise and it's both a sequel
to 2018's Bumblebee and a prequel to The
Original film this one takes place in
1994.
new box joining The Fray include Peter
Dinklage as main Baddie Scourge
everything you cared for
will be consumed and Pete Davidson is
Mirage
Anthony and Dominique are the two humans
tasked with saving the world today we we
shot the the scene where we come to the
Sundial we almost fell to my death I'm
not gonna lie I was still in character
and she like fell for real
are you okay let them come
something else we can't wait to see
Disney's fresh take on Haunted Mansion
it hits the big screen July 28th nearly
20 years after the first flick with
Eddie Murphy they've made a new Haunted
Mansion movement
[Music]
is anybody else seeing this yeah I'm
seeing it
the all-star cast is stacked we're
talking Jared Leto Winona Ryder Danny
DeVito Tiffany haddish Rosario Dawson
and lakeith Stanfield to just name a few
oh let's add in Jamie Lee Curtis also
we're very much looking forward to
seeing your take on Madame Leota there's
a question about how did she get into
the crystal ball so we may answer that
question
is she a Sagittarius like me we'd be
texting each other and stuff I try to
match my hair to her hair yeah inspired
by the iconic attraction the comically
creepy Adventure follows a mother and
son who hire a team of so-called
spiritual advisors to oust their
Supernatural squatters I'm going to
light a vanilla candle and it's going to
be a game changer
go some of these ghosts in this in this
movie feel real
so I was doing a lot of praying that's
where Owen Wilson enters the chat as a
priest what are you gonna do
seriously yeah they're already dead
you're gonna be deader the cast that
they put together and stuff just seemed
great and then the sets and the sort of
you know ideas for it I feel like we're
pretty good we all have fun get ready
for more family fun with the Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles they're out of the
sewer and back on the big screen in
their first new animated film in 16
years mutant Mayhem he's
did you hear that what was that
well not that we can do you guys want to
grab pizza and this one's making history
for the first time four actual teens are
the voices behind Donatello Michelangelo
Leonardo and Raphael we are so excited
to join Turtle history and we are not
the only ones
Seth Rogen's producing and starring in
the movie hitting theaters August 4th
along with Paul Rudd Maya Rudolph and
John Cena who's been known to rock some
Ninja fashion I was just getting in the
spirit of everything and how about the
stars behind this Marvel animated sequel
you say the fate of the Multiverse in my
brain does
new girls Jake Johnson Haley Steinfeld
Spidey himself shamik Moore and Issa Rae
as Spider-Woman are among the Celeb
voices in Spider-Man across the
spider-verse if I hadn't said it before
by the way you're a terrible mentor to
play Jessica Drew this eight months
pregnant badass crime fighting hero I
mean it was a dream come true the team
behind this movie is so out of this
world the first film into the
spider-verse won an Oscar and took in
384 million at the box office
Tom Holland Toby Maguire hello and
Andrew Garfield are rumored to make
cameos in the sequel that hits theaters
Friday
this is unbelievable
so if they wanted to do spider Gwen and
Jessica Drew in live action would you
guys be game yeah
I personally would not yeah yeah right
yeah you gotta really try it like you
gotta beg me